notre rôle ici et 2 et de bâtir de
protéger de soutenir les civils
d'afghanistan pour cela il faut éviter
de les tuer coûte que coûte
on ne peut pas les aider et les tués en
même temps c'est humainement impossible
non on a débuté cette guerre il ya déjà
huit le vu votre réputation et votre
dynamisme
admirable notre espoir est que vous
obteniez tous les résultats escomptés se
souvient de general motors et l'homme
qui a donné un coup de pied dans les
couilles al qaïda y'a pas de voir
devenir vos troupes fait bouger le
curseur dans le bon sens présenter une
jolie série de graphiques
il faut en finir que c'est une cause
perdue on ne peut pas éternellement et
d'afghanistan
c'est pour ça que je vais gagner mon
équipe et moi allons prendre
un nouveau tournant vers quoi ce nouveau
tournant nous allons bâtir le pianiste
en enfer un pays de liberté de france
méritait bien souriez glen pour la
presse
ça ressemble beaucoup au tour précédent
je ne suis pas là pour jerry conflit je
refuse d'être venu pour enterrer cette
guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon travail est de veiller à ce que
votre ambition personnelle soit
contrôlée
tu vois c'est qu'on est là avec nos
flinguer tout en train d'essayer de
faire croire à ces gens là que c'est
nous les gentils il faut qu'on voit une
arme
si quelqu'un peut réussir c'est bien
vous
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas là pour gagner vous êtes
là pour nettoyer la merde
[Musique]